este es un vídeo especial hoy no vamos a
hablar de política como tal sino de
comunicación política es decir de cómo
vender mensajes para ganar una campaña
electoral
y lo vamos a hacer analizando la campaña
electoral de las elecciones españolas
como sabéis ayer mismo hubo elecciones
generales en españa y de eso es
precisamente de lo que vamos a hablar
hoy y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos si ya sois seguidores de visual
politics seguro que estaréis muy
sorprendidos como es posible que hayamos
sido capaces de hacer un análisis tan
rápido normalmente si conocéis este
canal ya sabéis que tardamos varias
semanas incluso meses para preparar un
vídeo investigamos hasta el último
detalle y por eso solemos decir que
estamos orgullosos de llegar tarde si
queréis a actualidad rabiosa tenéis un
montón de medios ahí fuera aquí vamos
mucho más allá y de hecho este vídeo lo
hemos grabado días antes de las
elecciones porque
[Música]
pues porque no vamos a centrarnos en los
resultados sino en la campaña electoral
como sabéis antes de ser youtuber
yo me dedicaba precisamente a trabajar
en elecciones así que hoy vamos a hacer
un análisis totalmente técnico vamos a
dejar a un lado las ideas políticas y
nos vamos a centrar en cómo vender ideas
porque la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos
es qué partidos tenían el mejor eslogan
de campaña cómo se diseña un buen cartel
electoral qué partidos han hecho la peor
campaña electoral qué decisiones y cómo
piensa un consultor de marketing
electoral hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
da igual desde donde estáis viendo este
vídeo si os gusta la política españa
está viviendo una edad de oro de las
campañas
[Música]
tenemos de todo un primer ministro que
perdió el gobierno tras una moción de
censura en el parlamento una crisis
constitucional en toda regla con una
región cataluña que quiere separarse del
resto del país
y todo esto alineado con la salsa
picante del estancamiento económico
vamos que sólo nos falta un presi del
cromo y precisamente en este contexto es
cuando han aparecido montones de
partidos políticos nuevos veréis hasta
el año 2014 las elecciones españolas se
resumían en dos partidos políticos el
partido popular de centroderecha y el
partido socialista de centroizquierda
por supuesto que también existía un
enorme abanico de partidos locales que
tenían y tienen un poder enorme en su
región lo que en españa' llamamos los
nacionalistas
también teníamos otros partidos más
pequeños que efectivamente presentaban
candidatos en toda españa- pero que
vamos a ser honestos les votaría su
padre su madre y su prima en otras
palabras que por aquellos años este país
se consideraba una democracia
bipartidista y eso qué significa desde
el punto de vista de la estrategia
política pues básicamente que las
elecciones eran lo que se conoce como un
juego de suma cero un juego de suma cero
es un tipo de juego donde lo que pierde
uno lo gana el otro es decir bastaba con
que tu contrincante perdiera popularidad
para que automáticamente la ganarás tú
por ejemplo en el año 2011 la derecha
ganó las elecciones sin apenas hacer
ningún esfuerzo por qué pues porque los
votantes estaban muy decepcionados con
el gobierno que era de izquierdas
presidencial de josé luís rodríguez
zapatero y como los escaños del
parlamento son un número fijo 350
diputados pues lo que perdía el 1 lo
ganaba el otro y viceversa en otras
palabras que por aquel entonces las
elecciones eran más aburridas que un
maratón de las chicas gilmore
[Música]
pero no sólo eso veréis en españa' las
elecciones al parlamento tienen
circunscripción provincial y esto qué
significa pues que un votante de madrid
vota a una lista de candidatos cerrada
que son los candidatos por la provincia
de madrid y lo mismo pasa con un votante
de barcelona vota a la lista de
candidatos de la provincia de barcelona
cada provincia tiene más o menos escaños
dependiendo de la población por ejemplo
yo soy de valladolid que es una
provincia pequeñita de unos 300 400 mil
habitantes en mi provincia mira que os
lo voy a enseñar aquí tenemos una
papeleta de estas elecciones todavía no
votado y ni siquiera sé qué papeleta es
pero aquí podéis ver que hay cinco
nombres verdad esto es porque hay cinco
escaños pues bien en un sistema
bipartidista estos cinco escaños siempre
se van a repartir de la misma forma tres
para uno y dos para otro en el caso de
valladolid que siempre ha sido un
bastión de la derecha
el resultado era tan fascinante como un
solo de triángulo tres escaños para los
populares dos escaños para los
socialistas punto pelota y todo esto
explica que en aquella época pero seamos
honestos la campaña electoral era un
mero trámite mirad por ejemplo un spot
eh
del partido popular en el año 2011
[Música]
sumate al cambio votan partido popular
sin embargo a partir del año 2014 las
cosas cambiaron para siempre con estos
dos señores que veis en pantalla que se
llamaban abre iglesias e íñigo errejón
estos dos caballeros eran profesores de
ciencias políticas en madrid y habían
trabajado toda su vida como asesores de
campaña en izquierda unida izquierda
unida era uno de estos partidos
minoritarios de extrema izquierda que
les votaba su padre su primo su vecino
en el año 2014
tanto rejón como iglesias se marcharon
de este partido y montaron su propio
proyecto político un spin-off al que
llamaron podernos
[Música]
y elecciones europeas 2014 podemos se
convierte en una sorpresa y logra cinco
escaños en estrasburgo desde el punto de
vista del marketing político podemos es
algo así como el google de la política
algo disruptivo algo nunca visto que
cambió la escena española para siempre
de repente ya no había dos partidos
grandes sino tres pero atentos porque la
historia no termina aquí efectivamente
podemos consiguió arrasar en el hueco
que quedaba a la izquierda del partido
socialista
[Música]
pero la cosa no termina aquí seguimos
por el año 2014 por aquel entonces la
economía española no termina de mejorar
y los medios están copados por la crisis
catalana por si todo esto fuera poco el
gobierno conservador de mariano rajoy
parecía que coleccionaba escándalos de
corrupción en otras palabras que había
un hueco para otro partido más un
partido que estaría en el espacio
ideológico que quedaba entre los
socialistas y los populares es decir en
el centro y este partido era ciudadanos
[Música]
exacto en las elecciones de 2015 los
españoles ya no teníamos dos ni tres
partidos a elegir sino cuatro y aquí es
cuando la política española dejó de ser
un juego de suma cero para convertirse
en lo que conocemos como un juego
cooperativo en un juego cooperativo el
hecho de que tu contrincante pierda no
significa que tú vayas a ganar en otras
palabras aunque en el año 2015 el
partido popular iba a perder muchos
escaños en el parlamento eso ya no
significaba que los fueran a ganar los
socialistas podían ganar los ciudadanos
o podemos en otras palabras que de
repente los partidos políticos se
jugaban mucho en la campaña electoral y
creedme esto se nota recordáis ese
anuncio que os puse antes del partido
popular pues mirad lo que hicieron ese
mismo partido político en el año 2016
pero si la última vez que hablamos me
dijo que era seguro pero con la nueva
situación política todo separado pues
voy a dejar esto es transada contaba con
ese dinero el balance octubre
un desastre
solo con sonrisas no se puede hacer
funcionar un país no hay más preguntas
señoría creo que la diferencia salta a
la vista dejando a un lado las
ideologías este spot es una obra de arte
está dirigido a un público concreto y da
una razón clara para que les voten pero
esperad un momento porque los juegos
cooperativos tienen otra característica
muy interesante como su propio nombre
indica exigen que todos los jugadores
cooperen y eso en política se traduce en
pactos electorales con solo dos grandes
partidos formar gobierno era un juego de
niños sin embargo ahora ya no hay
ganadores claros y las coaliciones de
gobierno son la norma todo esto explica
que repetir elecciones se haya
convertido en una tradición tan española
como la paella la siesta y criticar a
enrique bunbury y aquí es cuando
llegamos a estas últimas elecciones de
diciembre de 2019
en este caso ya no tenemos 4 y 5 sino 6
partidos políticos que se presentan a
nivel nacional y que tienen
posibilidades de entrar en el parlament
o habéis oído bien 6 partidos
eso significa competición salvaje por
supuesto que hacer unas elecciones
convocadas casi por sorpresa los equipos
de campaña no han tenido mucho tiempo
para preparar sus estrategias pero en
cualquier caso ahora vamos a ver muy
buenos ejemplos de muy buena
comunicación política
[Música]
y aquí es donde viene el análisis que
estabais buscando vamos a ver los 6
pósters de campaña de los 6 grandes
partidos que se presentan y ya lo sé
estamos en 2019 los carteles de campaña
ya no son tan importantes como lo eran
hace 30 años hoy en día la auténtica
batalla está en la televisión o en
internet pero aún así los carteles
siguen siendo algo así como un flagship
de la campaña un símbolo y una forma de
ver cómo estar enfocando la campaña a
los distintos partidos así que estáis
listos pues vamos con ello
la campaña electoral en pósters la
primera regla de la comunicación
política es no importa que te quieran
solo que te voten un buen estratega de
campaña no busca hacer ni cosas bonitas
ni cosas originales busca hacer cosas
que ganen votos entre un nicho de
potenciales votantes es decir es muy
importante tener en cuenta el mensaje y
el público al que va dirigido por
ejemplo este anuncio si piensas votar me
creyendo que al fin y al cabo cuando sea
presidente del gobierno me cortaré la
coleta y mire como de espaldas indie
vestir hay según lo que me digan unos
asesores de imagen gracias pero no me
votes si piensas votar me creyendo que
nuestra soberanía se limita al peñón y
no a la banca la evasión fiscal y los
fondos buitres gracias pero no me votes
tal vez muchos de los que veáis este
anuncio no terminéis estando convencidos
de votar a podemos en este caso es muy
probable que sea porque no sois el tipo
de público al que va dirigido así que
recordad no estamos buscando el amor
universal de todos los ciudadanos sino
los votos necesarios para ganar las
elecciones ese es el único objetivo la
segunda regla de la comunicación
política es que
absolutamente todos los elementos que
usamos tienen que estar a disposición
del mensaje que queremos transmitir
[Música]
cada palabra en un discurso cumple un
objetivo pero no solo hablamos con
palabras la imagen es un lenguaje en sí
mismo así que él diseñó un póster de
campaña es muy importante dicho esto
vamos con los carteles los he colocado
en orden de mejor a peor y de nuevo no
estamos hablando de qué partido tiene
las mejores ideas ni de a qué partido he
votado hoy vamos a centrarnos en la
comunicación política y por eso
empezamos con el mejor de todos los
posters de campaña el póster de podemos
y su candidato pablo iglesias este
póster es una auténtica obra maestra de
la política
podemos con más país el partido más a la
izquierda de españa desde que nacieron
se vendieron como el partido que
realmente representa al ciudadano de a
pie a la gente trabajadora que en su
narrativa estaría desatendida por los
políticos tradicionales y por eso a
diferencia de los carteles tradicionales
donde sólo aparece un candidato con un
fondo neutro aquí vemos un montón de
gente detrás del político gente por
supuesto que está muy bien seleccionada
para mostrar diversidad de género de
raza y de edad pero no sólo eso fijaos
en dos detalles muy importantes el
encuadre y el ángulo en casi todos los
pósters de campaña el candidato aparece
en un primer plano de tal forma que
cuando lo vemos impreso en una valla
publicitaria vemos una cara gigantesca
en este caso sin embargo pablo iglesias
aparece en un plano medio en un plano
casi general como si fuera una persona
más un ciudadano cualquiera y además la
foto está hecha desde arriba normalmente
cuando queremos ensalzar una persona
colocamos la cámara desde abajo en lo
que se llama un contrapicado pero en
este caso está arriba mostrando que
pablo iglesias es lo dicho un ciudadano
más su nombre del pueblo votarle a él
significa votar al pueblo y por eso el
eslogan tiene un doble significado
fijaos bien un gobierno contigo por un
lado es una referencia más al pueblo al
que dice representar y por el otro es
una referencia al pacto electoral que
está dispuesta a hacer y con quién
quiere pactar pablo iglesias exacto con
los socialistas que son el gran partido
del centroizquierda y precisamente ese
es el segundo mejor cartel de esta
campaña
si el cartel de paro iglesias era una
imagen amable que muestra a una persona
cercana el de los socialistas es todo lo
contrario porque pues porque pedro
sánchez no puede presentarse como un
nombre del pueblo es es el presidente
del gobierno en su caso su gran
fortaleza es precisamente el hecho de
tener poder de que es muy probable que
termine siendo el próximo primer
ministro de españa y de hecho fue él el
que convocó las elecciones para
conseguir gobernar en minoría y
precisamente por eso su eslogan dice
ahora sí y luego hay un punto es decir
que ahora es la buena ahora por fin
vamos a gobernar y lo vamos a hacer
porque lo digo yo que miro a la cámara
con esa firmeza y esa seriedad de ser el
presidente del gobierno vamos a
transformar este país en la españa que
nos merecemos ahora sí
pero fijaos en otro detalle más hay una
característica muy típica en todos los
carteles que hacen los socialistas
romper los encuadres y las palabras es
decir la frase si os fijáis está cortada
en trocitos sin ningún sentido esto es
una marca de estilo que viene del año
2004 en ese momento es cuando los
socialistas ficharon a un publicista que
se llamaba joan camarín este hombre
introdujo grandes innovaciones en las
fotos de campaña hasta entonces todos
los candidatos normalmente solían
aparecer así
a partir de campmany los candidatos
socialistas empiezan a aparecer con la
frente cortada por arriba solo con la
mitad izquierda de la cara o mostrando
detalles muy específicos lo podéis ver
en estas fotos en opinión de camps man y
esto sirve para transmitir esa imagen de
juventud cambio y progresismo con la que
se quiere identificar el centroizquierda
y desde entonces han seguido manteniendo
esta línea estética esta línea gráfica
en las distintas campañas incluso
después de haber dejado de trabajar con
kallman pero fijaos porque este póster
tiene también algo muy interesante
fijaos en la imagen los que seáis de
españa' lo vais a notar enseguida lo
notáis que falta algo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
fijaos bien es el póster de un candidato
para unas elecciones un candidato del
partido socialista pero y dónde está el
lobo solamente vienen las siglas del
partido pero no está en la famosa rosa
con el puño porque se les ha olvidado
pues no obviamente no se les ha olvidado
han quitado el logo a propósito porque
pues muy sencillo porque no quieren que
votes pensando en un partido político el
mensaje central de la campaña del psoe
es que ya son el presidente del gobierno
es decir es el voto útil y el voto a la
estabilidad si quieres un gobierno firme
tienes que votar a pedro sánchez
olvídate de las siglas y las ideologías
por un momento porque ahora toca formar
gobierno como veis es un mensaje simple
sencillo y muy efectivo así que vamos
con el siguiente póster
[Música]
el partido popular es el gran partido de
centroderecha hasta el año 2015 este
partido solía trabajar con agencias de
publicidad muy pequeñas pero en los
últimos años han empezado a fichar
empresas muchísimo mejores en las
últimas campañas por ejemplo estuvieron
trabajando con shackleton y ahora están
trabajando con un ojo para que os hagáis
una idea no jo es una de las agencias
que más premios está llevando en los
últimos años de hecho los mismos que
hacen los anuncios de beefeater o de
yaguará en españa son los que hacen la
publicidad del partido popular dejemos
atrás nuestras diferencias y pensemos
sólo en aquello que nos une y nos hace
fuertes
[Música]
hagámoslo por 47 millones de razones y
así es como tenemos este póster fijaos
la diferencia con los pósters ya díaz el
partido popular hace sólo 4 años
si os dais cuenta hemos pasado de una
luz neutral a una luz natural una luz
que transmite esperanza fijaos que los
brillos blancos resaltan los ojos y las
facciones del candidato es una foto
radiante y la expresión del candidato de
pablo casado tampoco es pura casualidad
es dura pero a la vez es amable es como
un nuevo día es el cambio que representa
el pp que me decís del eslogan por todo
lo que nos une en un momento donde los
separatistas catalanes tienen titulares
de prensa y donde parece que los
partidos políticos no se pueden poner de
acuerdo el pp se presenta como el
partido de la unidad por sacar adelante
este país valiente inteligente audaz
creativo y solidario hagámoslo por
nuestro futuro
por todo lo que nos une sin duda alguna
este es el mejor póster de campaña de la
historia del partido popular quienquiera
que lo haya hecho se merece una buena
cesta de navidad de este año y por el
momento estos tres pósters son de lo
mejorcito que hemos visto nunca en
campañas electorales españolas ahora
vamos con la categoría más mediocre y
eso nos lleva a hablar de vox
box es el partido más a la derecha de
todos toda su campaña se basa en
patriotismo españa bandera y mano dura
contra los separatistas catalanes y por
eso su eslogan incluye la palabra
'españa' y tiene una bandera que muestra
el candidato a santiago abascal como un
líder fuerte se puede ver en su mirada
altiva que parece que está diciendo soy
santiago abascal y soy español por lo
demás es un cartel bastante clásico en
luz neutral candidato mirando de perfil
y fondo pues un fondo natural con unas
plantas algo de verde en fin que no es
una obra maestra pero hay que reconocer
que cumple su objetivo llega a los
potenciales votantes y manda un mensaje
atractivo si amas a tu patria como amas
a tu padre de nuevo un mensaje atractivo
para ellos si tú agotada podemos este
cartel no te va a gustar pero es que en
este caso tú no eres el público al que
se dirigen y ahora atentos porque vamos
a pasar de los diseños mediocres a los
realmente malos es decir los pósters que
probablemente lejos de ayudar a ganar
votos han servido para arrestarlos
en esta categoría tenemos que hablar de
más
país
para los que no lo conozcáis más país es
el partido más joven que se presenta en
estas elecciones y es un spin-off de
podemos es decir es otro partido que se
coloca a la izquierda del espectro y que
está dirigido por uno de los mejores
estrategas de campaña que ha tenido
españa íñigo errejón sin embargo no se
queda pasado este año porque creo que ha
patinado bastante este diseño es un
ejemplo perfecto de lo que os decía
antes lo importante en unas elecciones
no es que te quieran sino que te voten
[Música]
desde el punto de vista estético este
cartel es precioso podría ser el póster
de una película mira de ese original
llamativo y hasta diría que es bonito
pero qué sentido tiene que el candidato
esté con esos tonos verdes porque esa
cosa que parece una papeleta entrando en
la urna se trata de una imagen del
candidato que no destaca que si la ves
desde lejos ni siquiera la reconoces no
tiene un mensaje claro y el nombre del
partido eso es de izquierdas es de
derechas
y así quién va dirigido pues no se sabe
es un diseño muy bonito pero que no
cumple ninguna función pero tranquilos
porque si hemos dicho que este diseño
era malo todavía hay uno incluso
un cartel que muestra todo lo que nunca
hay que hacer en política y si estoy
hablando de este cartel
como decíamos antes y lo gano es el
partido que ocupa el espacio que queda
entre los socialistas y los populares es
el partido de centro el primer error de
este cartel es el eslogan o recuerda
exacto es un plagio descarado del
eslogan con el que manuel macrón ganó
las elecciones francesas hace dos años
es un plagio tan evidente que cualquiera
en españa con dos dedos de frente puede
darse cuenta así que el mensaje en este
caso es vamos a imitar a cualquier
político que esté de moda que hoy esa
mano al macrón emanuel macrón mañana que
se saldremos disfrazados de greta
samberg o de donald trump o de joker si
hace falta pero no sólo eso fijaos en la
composición no recuerda algo
exacto es la misma idea que el poster de
podemos pero marets a veréis en este
caso también vemos al candidato albert
ribera rodeado de gente también está en
plena acción es decir no está posando
sino que está caminando pero el problema
es que en el póster de podemos estar en
un entorno natural por supuesto que la
foto de pablo iglesias tiene hasta el
último detalle cuidado pero no es un
montaje o al menos no lo parece la foto
de ciudadanos sin embargo está hecha en
un estudio y se nota
mirad el fondo neutro la luz es un
quiero y no puedo quiero ser natural
pero no soy capaz por un lado quieren
presentar al candidato rodeado de
seguidores pero el mensaje que
transmiten es que todo es fake todo es
puro marketing de nuevo no estoy
diciendo ni que me guste podemos ni que
no me guste ciudadanos pero desde el
punto de vista de la campaña de esta
campaña está claro quién ha hecho un
mejor trabajo tanto en el póster como en
el resto de la estrategia
de nuevo no estoy diciendo ni que me
guste podemos ni que no me guste
ciudadanos pero desde el punto de vista
de la campaña está claro quién ha hecho
un mejor trabajo tanto en el póster como
en el resto de la estrategia pero ahora
llega a vuestro turno cuál ha sido la
campaña que más os ha gustado en estas
elecciones y a los que nos estáis viendo
desde latinoamérica que partidos parece
que hacen las mejores campañas en
vuestro país olvidaos de las ideologías
por un momento y vamos a hablar de
comunicación política podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre recordad que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribimos a visual político y gracia
de la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]